اذا برهان عن التين
في هذا المشروع من ليبرالي التطبيعي داخل
احد مساجد الخرطوم تسمع الاصوات الرافضه
لمساعي الحكومه الانتقاليه الاستمرار في
التطبيع مع اسرائيل
وخارج المساجد لا يختلف الموقف فبنظر
هؤلاء لا يحق لحكومه انتقاليه المضي في
هذه الخطوه برهان غير مفاوض من الشعب
السلطات الانتقاليه لا تقوم بقضايا ذات
الطبيعه الجذريه يعني سلطه غير مفوضه من
الشعب لا يجوز لها على الاطلاق ان تقوم
بقضايا جذريه يعني الامر الثاني ان
التطبيع الذي فعله البرهان هو يخالف قيم
الشعب السوداني قوى سياسيه وتيارات
اسلاميه واجسام مهنيه عده اعلنت رفضها
للتطبيع مع اسرائيل هي تصدر المشهد حزب
البعث العربي الاشتراكي وحزب المؤتمر
الشعبي وتجمع المهنيين السودانيين والقوه
الشعبيه لمقاومه التطبيع تبدو اسرائيل
راغبه في استكمال ما تبقى من ملفات لاعلان
اتفاقها الرسمي مع السودان وبالنسبه الى
بعضهم فان البرهان يطبق ما جاء في الاتفاق
الايطالي مع القوه السياسيه بشان الطبيعه
العلاقات مع الدول اتفاق الاطار نفسه
يدعو الى علاقات متوازنه مع جميع الدول
ولذلك اعتقد لا يعوز البرهان مبررات
واعتقد ان ما يفعله هو تنفيذ ليس ابتدار
لمسار جديد
ومنذ اعلان اولى خطوات التطبيع مع اسرائيل
في فبراير من عام 2020 ظلت الاجسام
الرافضه للتطبيع في حراك شعبي مستمر ملف
التطبيع يجب حسمه عبر مؤسسات المنتخبه
يقوله هؤلاء مع تجديد على اولويه القضيه
الفلسطينيه وعدالتها
بدل الموقف السوداني الرسمي واضحا حيال
الاستمرار في عمليه التطبيع مع اسرائيل
موقف يقابل برفض شعبي وسياسي من قبل
كيانات مختلفه ترى ان الحكومه الانتقاليه
الحاليه غير مفاوضه للبث في قضيه مهمه
كالتطبيع مع اسرائيل نزار البقدونس